منذ السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)، لم
يصبح الفلسطينيون هدفًا
للقصف الإسرائيلي فحسب، بل أيضًا
للرواية الفلسطينية، فقد رأينا كيف تم استهداف الصحفيين في
غزة مراسلين على الأرض
بالصواريخ الإسرائيلية، وقد قُتل ما لا يقل عن
24 صحفيًا فلسطينيًا
مع كل العالم أجمع.
أسرت وتألمت من أه ما
حدث لمراسل قناة الجاز في غزة
عندما استهدفت إسرائيل عائلته
وقتلت زوجته وطفليه
ومع ذلك في اليوم التالي وقف ليواصل
نقل الحقيقة
بينما كان يحاول القيام بعمله في
أحد  من أصعب المواقف التي
عرفها الإنسان على الإطلاق، بدون ماء، بدون
طعام، بدون وقود كهرباء، رأينا
كيف نشطت وسائل الإعلام الرئيسية في
تجريد الفلسطينيين من
إنسانيتهم، وإضفاء الشرعية على
ارتكاب جرائم الحرب
وانتهاكات حقوق الإنسان من قبل السلطات الإسرائيلية في
غزة وتبريرها.  لم تقم السلطات الإسرائيلية
بقطع المياه والغذاء والدواء فحسب، بل
قامت أيضًا بقطع الاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية
والوصول إلى الإنترنت، ونعلم جميعًا ما
يعنيه التعتيم المعلوماتي، ومع ذلك، فإن
المعلومات القليلة التي تمكنت من الوصول إلى قطاع غزة
وثلاث مرات خرجت من قطاع غزة رأينا
كيف تمكنت شركات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من الوصول إلى هذه المعلومات  لقد أخذوا
دورهم في تضييق الخناق على
الرواية الفلسطينية، وتم
حذف الصفحات من المحتوى، وتم نقل REM، وتم تعليق التعليق،
والناس بشكل عام
كانوا آه، وكان الناس بشكل عام
يبلغون عن كيفية قمع المحتوى الخاص بهم عن فلسطين،
وشعر القطاع المحظور في الظلام تمامًا
خارج الشبكة تمامًا، لا توجد
اتصالات ولا رسائل نصية قصيرة ولا
إنترنت، وهذه حقًا
لحظة مرعبة في تاريخنا حيث
نعرف مرة أخرى ما تعنيه عمليات الإغلاق المتبادل
أنها تعني المزيد من الفظائع وانتهاكات حقوق الإنسان